نحن اناس بسطاء عملنا كثيرا لتاسيس حياتنا
وها هو منزلنا مدمر اطلب من الله شيئا
واحدا وهو ان تنتهي هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
ان هناك حقبه جديده تاسس ليس فقط في
العلاقات الثنائيه بين موسكو وبيجين بل في
التفاعل بينهما بينهما على الساحه الدوليه
على مختلف القضايا سونا الاقليميه او
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
كما يقول الذين ينتمون الى
ربما الخوف من خضات وهزات جيو سياسيه في
اشاره الى الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
تركيا بامكانها تاخذ دور كبير في الازمات
سواء كان على المستوى الاقليمي على وسواء
كان على مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
الكثيرين لم نسمح لروسيا ان تقسمنا كما
دعمنا اوكرانيا بالمعدات العسكريه ومن
خلال تمويل توليد الاسلحه الى بلد في حاله
حرب باستخدام موارد ميزانيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
هناك تحالف استراتيجي بدا يترجم على ارض
الواقع هي يبدا القرار بالفعل السياسي من
اعلى القمه الهرمين ان كان في ايران او في
روسيا وبالتالي يتدرج الى عمليه الماسه من
التدريب الى التعاون الى التبادل حتى الى
الدعم السياسي بالمشروع النووي الايراني
[موسيقى]